I think blending a family like that is
you know there's so many emotions
involved in so many kids and even though
I think it made it I would imagine so
much easier because we've all known each
other but you know there are emotions
changes hard for kids yeah it turns out
Kourtney Kardashian and Travis Barker's
kiddos are still getting used to their
big blended family I'm just like living
life and whatever happens happens the
Kardashian star opens up on the not
skinny but not fat podcast about what
life's been like for their children
since she and Trav tied the knot in May
I think we're in the place where we're
figuring out
how to blend our households and our fam
you know our kids and how does what does
life look like now you know so for the
most part I think it's we're getting
like those things in place like we do
family dinner every Sunday night with
all the kids at his house Court of
course shares three little ones with X
Scott Disick Mason Penelope and Rain
while Travis also has three of his own
with ex-wife Shayna Moakler Atiana
Landon and Alabama you know my main
concern is always you know my my
children are my first priority and you
know that's one thing that you know
Travis Knight you know do agree on it's
probably the only thing we agree on but
you know our children come first and
their happiness but even a few months
into their marriage the bunch is still
adjusting to their new Norm I think it
made it I would imagine so much easier
because we've all known each other and
we've all had our you know relationships
with each other and and know you know
each other's intentions and that we're
good people I can't imagine if it was
random someone else but you know there
are emotions change is hard for kids so
because of that everyone's still living
separately the court says they do have
plans to be Under One Roof they have
both lived in their homes their whole
lives for the most part and just they
each have their rooms and we are a block
away so it's kind of a special time that
we are like what a cool time that like
every night he can he comes over and
it's like our we have our routines
within our house oh and that routine
kravis has it down packed you know I get
up at six in the morning and and I
carpool every morning and then I go
straight to his house and have matcha he
has it ready for me and then we have
much and like talk and hang out and then
work out together and then we start our
day we're just you know living our best
lives and yeah and while the goal is to
get everyone all living together the
newlyweds say they're not in a rush
feel really you know passionately about
each each other and want to do
everything as quick as possible but then
yes like with the kids and I think just
keeping everyone in there comfortable
places yeah and feeling like oh it's not
as much change as I thought
[Music]